the monster verse is full of giant guide
you that dwarf any other real-life
creature by magnitudes and size they are
called Titans and these Titans are based
on both old kaiju designs and also quite
a few original ones there are the
underwater titles as we have discussed
in a previous video and also terrestrial
ones that we have yet to showcase but in
this video we will be introducing to you
the seven flying Titans of the monster
verse taken from the movies the comics
and the novelizations these tyrants are
the rulers of the sky and on occasion
they have proved themselves worthy
adversaries for both the terrestrial
tyrants and the other flying ones as
well so here's the list
the first one is grizzle Codel also
dubbed as Titanus grizzle gödel this is
a giant ikg created by legendary
pictures that appears in a 20-19 film
Godzilla king of the monsters as a name
briefly seen on a monitor in mythology
Quetzalcoatl was a feathered serpent
deity in the cultures of pre Colombia it
is not an original concept of the
monsters as there have been the group of
giant bird kaiju of the same name
created by Tristar pictures in the
series the adult quizzical could emit a
deadly stream of fire and balls of flame
from her mouth and was covered with a
special type of skin made of silicon
that allowed her to be unaffected by the
hottest of temperatures but in the most
of us we have yet to find out whether
this tyrant possesses similar powers or
if it is a completely different guide
you all together the second one is
Ghidorah this tyrant is the most well
known and the archrival of Godzilla the
three-headed dragon kaiju is not from
Earth and arrived on this planet
millions of years ago like most of his
past incarnations Ghidorah is larger
than Godzilla his middle neck has two
rows of spine while his left and right
necks have only one each head has a
crown of ten horns
and regarding his wings they are just
enormous easily a thousand feet across
in wingspan and can create hurricane
like winds and fly at supersonic speed
his heads have broken Dylan looking jaws
with flaring nostrils a forked tongue
and brows with a generally foreign
appearance and can shoot gravity beams
he is also the biggest island at 521
feet tall and over a hundred and forty
thousand tons and with a giant wingspan
he makes Godzilla look like a cute
little lizard number three the Shi
Nomura this next flying titan is an
original design called Shi Nomura and
was a very ancient Titan dating back to
the Cambrian period almost 250 million
years ago where it was confirmed that it
was a rival of the Godzilla species even
in the ancient times while it could
technically take on two different forms
the main form of ash in amaura was
massive winged insect like monsters with
blue scales and black membranous wings
they had a total of six eyes with there
being three on each side of the head
their bodies were long and serpentine
ending in sharp
scorpion like tails she numerous
gigantic super colony cells are black
and blue and resemble starfish she
Nomura
is a conglomerate of millions of smaller
creatures merge together to create one
single entity much like destroyer it was
finally killed in 1954 by Godzilla and
the US military the fourth one Rodan
coming up next is the flying pterosaur
Titan the fire demon called Rodan which
first appeared as the title character in
Ichiro Honda's 1956 film Rodin produced
and distributed by Toho just a bit of
trivia Roland's original name was radon
and his based on the name Pteranodon
this incarnation of Rodin has a larger
wingspan compared to any of his previous
incarnations his physique overall bears
strong resemblance to a bird of prey his
head possesses a large heavy light beak
lined with tooth like spikes and a pair
of horn Spurs curled down from the back
of his skull he is 154 feet tall weighs
more than
9,000 tons and has a wingspan of 871
feet across and also can fly at
supersonic speeds
Rodan has internal volcanic combustion
causing him to radiate heat the
temperature of which can reach up to up
to 1,200 degrees Celsius at number 5
comes Mothra up next is the queen of the
monsters and after her are two remaining
tyrants one which you have already seen
the movie and another one which only
appears in the comics well
Mothra's design in the monster verse
tells us that she is more than just
another cute moth
also dubbed as Titanus missourah she
shares a mutual symbiotic relationship
with Godzilla and she fights for her man
no doubt about that as a lava she bears
very similar resemblance to her older
incarnations but the adult version is
totally different a hairline body
feathery antennae and four large wings
would sweep up like a butterfly and they
are also bright and bioluminescent she
is 52 feet tall but it's just a posture
her wingspan however is 803 feet wide
and she has a stinger as a melee weapon
and also can shoot super silk as a
ranged attack her legs possess pointed
tips which she utilizes as blade like
weapons for combat against other tyrants
the sixth fly in Thailand is the mutual
male as said before this one is the
first massive unidentified terrestrial
organism or in short the mutant male
this tyrant is the male form of the Jin
Qin mushi super species which also
includes the female Muto the Queen Muto
and the muta prime none of them are
exactly the same but each one of them is
very similar to each other
despite this the male Muto is the only
one which has the ability of flight it
can fly long distances and at very fast
speed he has a height of 200 feet and a
very large wingspan the murrow's bodies
are covered in an iridescent metallic
grayish black exoskeleton they have
orangie red eyes narrowly shaped eyes
and their body can emit EMP which is
electromagnetic pulse and that blacks
out all electronics in a specified range
it has long slender hind limbs with flat
broad feet ending in two hoof like toes
and
the shape volumes for attack and the
last one the seventh Camazotz the last
flying title of the monster versus
Titanes Camazotz and this tyrant will
appear in an upcoming comic book in
which he will fight calm before the
events of godzilla vs kong the name
Camazotz literally meaning deaths back
was a mind bat God associated with night
death and sacrifice this name was likely
chosen due to cameras our strong
resemblance to a bat and due to his
godlike status as a Titan capable of
challenging Kong Camazotz is a massive
creature with demonic horns as well as
large bat-like wings covered in long
sharp spikes he also has what appears to
be black colored fur covering the
entirety of his body his jaws are filled
with dozens of jagged dagger-like teeth
and as seen in the end credits of king
of the monsters an image of a bat using
echolocation would have probably been
him and that's all about the seven
flying titles of the most of us and so
be sure to LIKE share and subscribe to
this channel for more monster videos